agradezco mucho a todos
a veces cuando va creciendo en
escenarios así
y esas cosas
se puede decir
ok entonces al final y empezamos como a
creer no medio minuto empezamos a creer
que todo el cuerpo
hablar de las cuestiones
pero es que hay grandes desigualdades
entre hombres y mujeres con espacios por
ejemplo las mujeres cuando nos
levantamos todos los días a mañana
es mejor que vaya más provocadores
[Música]
i
otras mujeres para comprar el vino
visitando en mil cosas
las emisiones de co2
hablamos de que hace una diferencia de
los hombres y su posición organizado a
diario y eso es precisamente por la
hipersexualización de los retos
porque no es lo mismo
mucho
gracias a estas cosas
también gracias a dios exactamente la
posición de facebook hizo un experimento
social le dijo un señor como son estos
hábitos para entonces
[Música]
para tomar a la transexual
era una mujer porque es la
hipersexualización de nuestros cuerpos
porque todo es y personalizarlos los
cuerpos de las mujeres a nadie le sirve
porque esa es la realidad que estamos
viviendo
[Música]
extensión de la violencia sistémica que
se vive en las calles las colonias de
las casas en la escuela cuando ejemplo y
estas paso al espacio digital y esta
personalización daña
hicimos una gran violencia es la trata
de mujeres que la decisión es de 95 500
-3 con el pan o la luz que viene de la
casa
i
y siempre quieren que nosotros hemos de
darnos a respetar y tenemos el placer y
no podemos ver otra vida sexual y
siempre
o sexual
[Música]
a la información
no es este espacio nosotros
en una vida paralela no es real algo que
puede afectar a todos
[Música]
y no sintamos esposo necesitamos porque
él
[Música]
pero no
entonces comenzamos hace exactamente así
5 años una lucha podría ingresar o
regresamos
tanto nuestra actualización así porque
una vez yo tenía una pareja de estas
parejas horas por sobre todas las cosas
así es que el hombre más guapo del
universo y después no horas
[Música]
sumamente mal
entonces cosas y así una vez que él
propuso hacer un libro sexual
y qué
porque además será una compañera no
quiso hacer con el campo hacer un vídeo
para mostrarle las obras
porque había una iglesia y las demás
me perdonas hay tantas cosas
y vamos
a
[Música]
y yo de verdad cimientos
demostráis combatidas personas
[Música]
culpable
y entonces
las semanas
muchas
de mí
[Música]
y en tecnología
y yo
qué es
el día a día
mi familia es reconocida a nivel
internacional
pero de situación municipal es decir
redes sociales
y menciona que si podemos tener es
olimpia por andar por la tierra y tiene
muy buena de bolsa
pasadas las semanas aproximadamente unas
semanas
[Música]
entonces
y entonces
y yo dije
con este sabor nos prestan el teléfono
lo ve y lo empieza a ver delante de mí
obviamente yo lo primero que dije fue
que horror en nervios que tu familia
normalmente esté viendo teniendo sexo
estaba yo sumamente triste olvidar por
supuesto que yo me quería ir a cualquier
otro lugar del país yo no sabía qué
hacer
este es el país que me dice no hija
todos cogemos la diferencia es que a ti
te ven [ __ ] y eso que te hace menos
mujer
yo dije yo no entendía obviamente yo
creo que efectivamente es una mujer
y a partir de ahí empezamos una lucha y
empezamos a decir que en pueblos los
padres en las redes sociales
a nivel 20 están más felices pues decía
que ya sé con quién te metes con
sicarios
en un anuncio las mujeres
vaya a esa calle nos culpas siempre a
nosotras 9mm y siempre a nosotras y
nosotros lo creemos porque siempre nos
enseñaron que cáritas
yo
por vivir sexualidad y las personas que
me subieron a las personas que
respondamos este vídeo actualmente en
las 66 páginas forma en todo el país y
no todo el contenido que ustedes en sus
celulares disponentes éxito
este es el intercambio de contenido del
tipo sexual con consentimiento
páginas como prueba puede faltar a las
niñas a finales de tensiones y tomar
fotografías en los pases hay páginas por
las dos bandas de hombres y para tomar
la suerte está coludido equipo
organizado sacar la captura de pantalla
de esa cámara la computación digital
no sé si no es ahí presenta lización de
nuestros cuerpos que por supuesto que se
traspasan al espacio digital nosotros lo
dimos permiso para hacer mirar nuestra
indignidad
a ninguna mujer que ustedes ven en el
pack en la luz quieren que ustedes
porque las libertades
y después de esta historia después de
haber después comenzamos un frente
nacional para la seguridad comenzamos a
ver qué
[Música]
es el problema
y esto hace que te sientas sola que
nadie te respalda y nadie crea ciertas
asegura estabilidad hemos propuesto al
país a prueba de puebla y además
atención los casos gratis completamente
gratuitos
porque yo sé que se siente estar por ahí
una infinidad de explosiones tras
conocer nuestras casas nuestros cuerpos
internet pero ponemos en la historia que
hay otras
mucho de violencia digital lo virtual es
real si existe y si daña